R and digging for that pipe but the Flyers
win that Battle tip it gets it ahead BRS to
frost Frost to ludes one check m's on
it try to get it back to Brink it was
ever so slightly deflected that set it off
course he bches in from behind the net Frost
planked it off of Saros and in dirty but
good the Flyers take a one- nothing lead
space keep an eye on the bouncing Puck oh my
goodness off the skate off the back of yuss
Sorrow you may not see that again this season you
talk about a fortuitous bounce there it is time
he got the shot off it's blocked and now forsberg
has a step forsberg cutting in on goal forsberg
unable to finish it Aron fouls him across as the
Flyers move back fortunate to still be ahead in
this game here's cier looking for Stalin front
Mark do hammering away and it dribbles wide try
to get control to get control of the puck they
move up and connecton with the puck lton dangle
to the back hand save Soros gives them the lead
how often have we seen this this year short-handed
Lon and connect generating a scoring chance and
now forer moves in ends up laying down on the ice
as he was met by ker Flyers dig the puck loose
but Couer couldn't handle it it ends up being an
odman rush for the Predators they get it past the
line and here's Cole Smith Smith moves in the shot
and he scores shorthanded goal for the Predators
Smith beating Arison and instead of adding to the
lead the Flyers are now in a tie game it's 1-1
and watch where rist of lining goes here he goes
with the initial Puck carry that leaves Smith for
Frost and that's a difficult play for a forward to
defend against a guy coming with speed and Frost
elected to kind of take away any type of passing
option and Smith able to get it to his forehand
riy right at the line holds Waits giving a lot
of room he'll play it down low back Ender save
harison and that's forsberg not a guy you want
to see in that position scramble last opportunity
look at the hands there on forsberg boy can he
stick handle in a phone booth is actually where
that landed you worry about his thumb absolutely
fers win the draw Frost tried to Quick shot his
F now C out low SC Nifty maneuvering in tight by
cier power play Go the Flyers are back on top so
good for the Flyers to get one back on the power
play you give up a short-handed goal in your last
power play opportunity you just know that that
doesn't sit well off the face off here win a puck
Frost does that second effort kicks it to cier and
then the patience look at this play I thought it
actually trending actually helped it out I thought
Frost made that pass but once Saros goes for the
Poke check cier knows that if he can find a way to
get around that stick and open up sorrow that that
five hole is going to be exposed and cier puts it
home L spun off theck by thomasino Morgan stays
after it but now it deflex free and there's San
and the pass for brink is Off the Mark that turn
over there Novak moving in Novak to thomasino and
he scores [Applause] and the Predators respond
quickly TI it right back up at two Scrappy group
an eron pass creates a turnover and from there
the PRS can make some quick work good Patience
by Novak to find the the lane underneath the Stick
of York and then the patience by thomasino I mean
you can tell that he's got bent through and F he
tracks it down Stutter Step move by far centers
it in front Atkinson poking away but Sorrows
predators are really bounding pucks well in
this game they win another Puck battle forsberg
across Barry in front and they between the legs
tip Tri O'Reilly's blocked by Aron net and there's
the penalty on Walker right there on the back door
as he takes down Gus forsburg in O'Reilly knocked
down Nashville bench wanted another penalty they
don't get it they get one well that one went
up later here's a shot score oh maybe they're
saying High stick that deflected in the stick
was up high and now one refere it's called it
Cody Beach will call the high stick he look
at it any it has to be above the crossbar and
oh yeah that is above the cross that that's
no problem I mean that is not going to be a
goal but for the PRS they will have a five on
three cuz there was a delayed penalty on the
Flyers if it's directly into the net the high
stick is determined by the crossbar if it's a
normal play [Music] it's Ryan pu the call on
the ice is no goal the puck was directed in
the net with a high stick on the same play we have
Philadelphia number 14 has two minutes connecting
with that original shot now here's Frost want to
get the puck on net he did save SARS up high now
Frost back out to rist line SARS has his stick
back here's M the other side the shot play and
going to look at the work of UC Soros with no
stick Predators will get a power play sanheim
Down Low York a shot and the save by SOS as York
snuck behind the defense there lton gets to this
Puck he's got tippet with him there's the pass
tippet cutting on in with the back head save
Soros and no rebound to be had after the PRS
cross SE it a couple of times in a near Miss
said off to O'Reilly lot of Talent on this
power play bar down low redirection try got
caught up and then forber got a shot Off
harison made the save just dead watch the
initial attempt here watch how he wants to go
get it if he reaches out then he opens up and
there could be a chance con actually match
the puck this way but then forer dropped it
off into a turnover thomasino to Smith for
the shot save Aron rebound Aron stop Smith
again able to kill the play in the neutral
zone good job by Luke Shen and then a good
feed there and that shot by Smith not once
but twice two real important to get it to the
point9 outut here's Walker he's got a man
ahead of the field it's Atkinson Atkinson
in on goal s slays out wasn't sure where it
was but it's underneath him Saros had other
ideas gains the line gives to kky KY will backand
back to CER he tried to Center second try got in
first the line in back H her save and the rebound
poked away and the eventual chance here for rist
the line and as he snuck in good C was born to
be a flyer wasn't he yeah how long he remains
one we'll see there's Walker stripped at the
line Atkinson fighting hard to get back but
now sizin has it sizin on the left wing hole
sizin into the middle of the shot they score
thomasino beating Arison and with 401 to go
the competitors lead for the first time thino
does the work strips the puck at his own
blue line and then watch this pass by Siz
I mean patience Catch and Release you got to get
around that puck once you get it see ainson kind
of Shades towards the point and that is what
opens up the lane give him a little time and
space and thomasino in overtime with Washington
so both teams pi picking up points in those games
it's just a very competitive T division yep
break the pass back out there the winding the
shot and he misses the net here's Forester one
last chance 7even seconds CH for the point by
Walker's block the other way goes Nyquist to put
it away 2 seconds one and in it goes just before
the horn Predators will end the Flyers point
streak at nine here in Philadelphia tonight
got some chances and rist of lining chance stood
out to me as one that was a good look he missed
the net then eventual shot block Springs ofs
the other way and Nyquist puts the game on Ice
there they work they compete
and they got a big performance
from Phil thomasino tonight and their
goenda getting pulled in his last start